>>I'm Andrew Ross Sorkin for the New York
Times here in Davos,
Switzerland, on day two of the World Economic
Forum's annual meeting.
You know, one of the issues that keeps coming
up, and we're hearing it
over and over again is this question about
capitalism, this question is
about free market, especially as so many world
leaders, politicians,
executives, regulators from around the world
look at the experience of
the United States and the financial crisis
in particular.
You know, a CEO from India said to me the
other day, you know, for the
past 20, 30 years we looked at the U.S. as
the bastion of capitalism,
the example that we hoped to be.
And we made that bet, as he said, he took
all that -- he said his
country took of its chips and moved them from
black to red on the
roulette table.
But now we're looking at the experience you
had in the U.S., and we're
saying, maybe we made the wrong bet.
I've heard the same thing from executives
and regulators in China, the
same thing from executives and regulators
in Europe.
I think it's a question that's going to go
much beyond this conference
here into conversation that's going to continue
at least for the next
several years.
I'm Andrew Ross Sorkin from the New York Times.
We're on NYTIMES.com/Davos, we've used throughout
the week.
Thanks so much.